les
quand d'aventuré appel
maintenant courait après avoir aidé les
mayas face à l'invasion espagnole
non pardon nos amis n'ont pas du tout et
des mayas ils ont fui l'époque en
laissant tout le monde se faire
massacrer
iris thomas elliot et la buse arrive
désormais dans une nouvelle époque fut
chaud ici dans mes bottes je détestais
ça bien autour de vous à part du saas
seulement je pouvais tu es le sable nous
sommes en egypte il ya précisément très
longtemps et 20 il ya tata changer tu
veux plus d'efforts désolé mais il fait
chaud et je vois bien qu'à chaque fois
vous vous en foutez de la date je
détecte les présences humaines derrière
celle d'une c'est super c'est peut-être
enfin mon père étant des moutons non pas
du tous des égyptiens à temps le mec il
m'envoie un message c'est ce qui me dit
vous conte vers la gauche serpent à
plumes plus bas ouais tu me connais un
chez le son chaud je le revois pied lyon
bonnes affaires la prostate excusez-moi
si l'auto fils parle pas de tir est
scotché sur son papy rue à bâgé le même
à la maison
à notre époque on avait des gravures sur
des pierres salut ils sont absorbés par
leur bac pyrrhus il parle des vrais les
deux sur de gouverneur est bon ça va
deux secondes quoi oui quoi eh ben on
cherche un homme avec un long manteau
blanc aussi vous voulez des informations
faut demander à la reine vont là vous
prenez tout droit 2e à droite quatre
concurrents étaient bourrés ouais mais
je ne vois pas de vous trouver quoi non
on parle des dunes pouvait pas louper
c'est la première pyramide je pensais
que la reine très bien nous recevoir
oui bon moi je vous conseille vous
arrivez vous proposer comme esclaves
sexuelles ça marche à chaque coup
cette reine m'intéresse fortement ma
chère rennes nous sommes des visiteurs
et comme preuve de bienveillance nouveau
au front cet esclave sexuelle tout à
fait que mon corps c'est toi ma copine
idées nouvelles
quel beau mot ressoures viril ça change
des brindilles dans mon royaume que vous
avez toute mon attention reine cléopâtre
nous cherchons quelqu'un dans les
environs un homme en blouse blanche
peut-être fallu à dire et maintenant mon
beau mâle enlève tes vêtements et montre
moi ta vous trouverez sur il a
probablement donné une relique est
quelqu'un ici non non non non non ne
dites pas seulement l'autre fois encore
déboulé avec ses énigmes à la cour on a
parlé d'une relique
mais oui j'ai ce que cherchait elle m'a
été donné par adieux en blanc j'ai pour
mission de la garder précieusement il
vous faudra la mériter
voici ma tête accusant ben non ils n'ont
pas dit non non ça casse le mystère il
se trouve que j'ai un chiffre après mon
nom celui qui trouve pour abc rosacée il
m'a tapé dans le mystère il faut garder
le mystère
bon ben voilà c'est moi imhotep tous
enchantés cap et 28 devant 54 bon
écoutez comment on peut récupérer cette
relique du tort qu'il suffit de résoudre
les énigmes que j'ai savamment
construite dans les profondeurs de cette
pyramide au bout du parcours se trouve
ce que rougerie parfait vous suivez mon
cousin flip a regretté quant à toi
oui on a plein de choses à se montrer ma
colonne
ça fait combien de temps qu'on marche là
ont pu voir rien on exploite la coupe
nous arrivons bientôt à la première
épreuve
j'en suis très fier personne n'a réussi
à le résoudre
vous n'avez aucune chance aux maires
dont souvenu nologie il ya ton compte
sur toi sinon il faut tu vas pas merci
je n'existe même plus nous y voilà
pour ouvrir la porte en pierre il faut
résoudre la puissante et micmacs que
j'ai confectionné mme yade on compte sur
toi je m'attendais là c'est super simple
il ya une torche allumée à gauche de la
porte et une étape à droite je prends la
torche de gauche et je lui faisais de
droite ça pas la musique elliott et j'ai
pas pu m'empêcher d'aller vinet mais
quand c'est possible
ah je vois un coup de chance ça peut
arriver mais bon plus cupides très bien
aux coulées continues est de toute façon
vous ne passerait jamais la deuxième
épreuve
d'ailleurs elle est juste devant vous
quoi le couloir exactement
il suffit de traverser le couloir les
iris mais qu'est-ce qui fait n'importe
quoi à quoi tu as failli tomber dans le
trou quel trouble mais b2 de quoi parlez
vous ayez ni aucun trou et regarde
devant au sol la terre allait retourner
la texture est différente tous les coups
c'est un tout avec des pics au fond mais
pas du tout à l'itie marché très fort et
qui est cette femme qui vient
d'apparaître au nom de couloir on dirait
le retour d'aller nord c'est parfait
alors viens par ici
qu'avez-vous dit allez viens jamais
proche d'abdullah mémoire va tomber elle
est cool
oh [ __ ] elle a de la chance elle
s'était déporté avant de tomber dans
l'été quand son jeu fait quelle magie
avez-vous déjouer les pièges vous
l'avait dit pour le trou au maire daley
encore parti avec ma machine à leimotiv
12 bonnes capacités d'analysé thomas
c'est rien ça fait 20 ans que je joue
aux jeux vidéo c'est toujours la même
chose regardez ça m'étonnerait que les
clés de la geôle d'une frégate du xviiie
siècle nous soit d'une quelconque
utilité
j'espère que tout va bien pour la buse
[Musique]
ses courses tout blanc c'est un vin
d'honneur vient me rejoindre assez
étrange
c'est la première fois que tu prends un
dingue c'est la première fois que je
prends un par ces cours est clair sur
maps l'insee tapo justement je n'avais
jamais vu regarde nombre à cause de moi
et faire chocolat au lait j'ai vu ça
chez mes amis l'émaillage adore tant
côté salle maintenant mon cochon ce que
tu vas faire c'est que tu vas n'admettre
d'ombré on met la pièce en forme de l
ici celle en forme de s la et enfin la
longue barre
support physique
ça me fait plaisir c'est un pote à moi
je t'en sors très bien que mercy
attention la tête j'ai l'impression
d'avoir fait salle comble avec
normalement j'ai une manette dans les
mains du voyeurisme
j'ai une question à se poser je sais
pourquoi je t'ai quitter du jour au
lendemain non sarah qu'une seconde pour
les flèches vous demandez pourquoi tu es
sorti avec quelqu'un comme moi je veux
bien qu'on n'a rien à voir si moche je
suis pas très intelligent j'ai aucune
culture générale c'est vrai qu'on voit
c'est vrai qu'on a rien à voir je sais
pas trop thomas mais quelque chose de
sincère au fond de toi que j'ai jamais
vue ailleurs je peux aussi de poser une
question bien sûr vite sur le côté on
laisse pas sa grosse boule puisque tu me
suis dans cette aventure
tu es plutôt du genre à éviter les
situations délicates et rester chez toi
c'est vrai que je suis pas courageux
mais quand je suis avec toi j'ai
l'impression que je peux me dépasser la
jeune je me sois utile pour la preuve de
ma vie où je comprends la reléguer les
larges en fait c'est le collier que mon
père m'avait offert quand j'étais enfant
sabri mais c'est du toc je récupère le
relais écoutez moi bien vous avez tout
le temps vous voulez pour y répondre
mais une seule proposition sinon vous
serez enfermé ici
qui suis-je le matin je marche sur 80
le midi c'est l'homme je me relis je
viens de l'inventer maire de laisser
moins en moins car il reste libre
regardez ce soit il faut rester une
minute dans les clubs mais il n'importe
quoi que c'était preuves existent pas
vous venez de foot le pain déluge c'est
pas du tout pas vous abandonner c'est ça
alors pas trop league
j'ai gagné mais personne peut survivre
dans des flammes c'est de la triche là
non je ne triche pas aux critères d'une
dame c'est une vraie épreuve
vous pouvez la surmonter alors allez-y
c'est une preuve des patrons il continue
signal vital et sommes maintenant pour
la relique années et des années
il faut quitter cet endroit marc planus
qui tu fais là fait pas des jeux sexuels
avec l'âge je parlais plus jeunes elle
m'a vidé de toute mon énergie je vais
mourir de fatigue c'est ça continue
partant à mort qu'elle me retrouve
elle m'a forcé pour que je rentre en
pierre mais je pense avoir plus la buse
tu t'es fait abuser elliott analyse
leurs locaux j'aurais bien voulu
connaître la suite mois analyse
j'ai trouvé la balise temporel un
batailleur du collier décryptage en
cause les données indiquent qu'une
dernière balise se trouve ailleurs à une
autre époque
marseille aussi en tout si le tampon
réalisation qui minogue est resté près
de moi
la balle revient la renommée des
accusations pénales temps
[Musique]
et voilà tout le monde est bien là is
comin g avec vous mes z'amis nous sommes
au complet
donc moi je suis là ah oui donc nous
sommes actuellement au japon en 11 150
dans le palais du shogun le show quoi
c'est qui c'est lui comme quoi les
nombreuses heures passées à jouer aux
jeux vidéo peut vous sortir d'une
situation délicate
ça arrive pas souvent mais ça arrive
désormais nos compagnons se retrouve
dans l'époque rio delle du japon dans le
palais du dirigeant militaire vont ils
retrouver la 3e reliques du docteur
chimie merci d'avoir écouté le septième
épisode de l'épopée temporal n'hésite
pas à ta bonnet et à mettre un pouce en
l'air et à la semaine prochaine